un samedi bien paisible au bord du lac
hora peering à un lac artificiel en fait
un des nombreux réservoirs de sao paulo
la métropole du brésil
[Musique]
on y pêche des petits poissons bien
petit les poissons car en 2015
il avait disparu il n'y avait plus d'eau
grave la crise très grave le niveau le
plus bas jamais atteint dans les trois
bassins qui alimente la métropole de
sein par l'eau en pompant le fond des
lacs il restait à peine trente jours
avant de mettre en place que les
autorités ont appelé le plan de fin du
monde
fournir de l'eau uniquement aux services
essentiels comme les hôpitaux et les
écoles vision de cauchemar dans cette
mégalopole de 22 millions d'habitants
gigantesque et danse concentration de
grands immeubles entrecoupés de favelas
anarchique la compagnie des zones
oracion pas la distribution mais diminue
le débit la population panique les plus
riches font creuser des puits
la majorité des foyers utilisent pour la
première fois l'eau avec parcimonie les
autorités ne sont pas à la hauteur la
saab sp la compagnie les eaux se
débarrasse de sa présidente et va
chercher cet ingénieur et professeur en
hydrologie qui arrive en plein milieu de
la crise en tout cas personne kelman a
eu de la chance il est plus normalement
jusqu'ici la sab s p est une société
publique à un peu plus de 50%
le reste est privée est cotée en bourse
au brésil et à new york
c'est la plus grande compagnie des eaux
d'amérique latine la sixième au monde
elle dessert 368 municipalités dont le
grand san paolo et près de 28 millions
de personnes
la crise a montré que les trois systèmes
de réservoir ne suffisait pas il a fallu
accélérer des projets co président de
traitement de san lorenzo
elle va chercher de l'eau à 50 km au
sud-est de san paulo lui fait gravir une
pente de 330 m grâce à des pompes
puissantes et ajoute 6 mètres cubes et
demi par seconde aux réserves de la
grande ville coût du projet 1 milliard
de dollars il vient tout juste d'être
inauguré
deuxième projet titanesque connecter le
bassin de réservoir de rio de janeiro à
celui de san paolo une canalisation de
20 km dont 6 de tunnels
ainsi on peut faire passer de l'eau de
rio de janeiro à 100 par l'eau ou vice
versa quand le besoin se fait sentir
grâce à un système de pompe réversible
jusqu'à 5 mètres cubes par seconde
aujourd'hui c'est la première fois qu'on
transfère de l'eau vers rio de janeiro
il y a quelques semaines le niveau des
réservoirs a recommencé à baisser de
façon inquiétante mais il a bien plu les
pêcheurs sont rassurés le pdg aussi
rassuré le niveau des réservoirs est
maintenant publié en continu sur
internet
le pdg garantie que l'eau est assuré
pour les 20 prochaines années
formez avec les toitures mais la menace
d'une autre crise n'a pas disparu la
crise peut simplement indiqué une vision
catastrophiste la monclar arrêté indique
une vision de précaution de prévention
et pour moi ce qu'il se pose c'est fait
vivions dollar arrêté plus que de la
crise mais s'être arrêté peut aboutir
dans une crise pourtant il n'ya pas si
longtemps l'état de sein par l'eau est
une région d'eau de bruyne mais 17
militante écologiste la bruine si
typique de san paulo a disparu plus de
5000 source également il ne reste plus
que 8 % de la forêt original da mata
atlantica à cause de ça le climat a
changé ce qui était hier de bruyne et
maintenant terre de sécheresse et de
tampons des tempêtes et des inondations
comme celles qui sont abattues sur la
région et qui ont fait 19 morts en mars
la forme de la pluie a changé dans ces
villes à cause de quoi
de la déforestation dans la
déforestation autour de rêver voir la
déforestation en face de la expansion de
l'agriculture dont l'état ne sont pas
l'eau principalement là
la can des sucres pour l'alcool et des
systèmes à la crise est venue de
l'incompréhension de l'écosystème et
aussi de ne pas pouvoir utiliser l'eau
d'un fleuve comme le riottier t la carte
de visite
l'identité de saint paul aux visites
le fleuve qui était qui traversent la
mégalopole est un égout à ciel ouvert
qui ne sera pas décontaminer avant dix
vingt ans dans cette favela qui borde le
réservoir
le tout à l'égout est installé il ya
deux ans avec des compteurs pour l'eau
courante pour laquelle il faut payer des
subventions sociales sont prévues
vu le nombre et l'état anarchique des
favelas le défi est immense
on continue à encourager l'économie
d'eau la saab sp ne prévoit pas de
situation catastrophique de sitôt mais
on ne peut jamais en être complètement
sur copenhague et maxime la nature a ses
mystères dit le pdg
pour sos mata atlantica la seule
solution est le reboisement massif et
systématique auquel les ong s'est
attaqué mais elle est encore bien seul
même si les brésiliens sont réputés pour
leur laisser faire légendaire elle n'est
pas pessimiste pour autant pessimistes
masque alerte à cause de son gigantisme
le cas de saint paul aux devrait sonner
l'alarmé pour le reste du monde
comment peut-on arriver à de telles
crises dans un pays qui possède 13 % des
réserves mondiales d'eau douce
awa fall fc flora de forêt pas d'audi
malo ribeiro aussi simple que ça il faut
remettre du verre dans ce drapeau
conclut-elle
[Musique]